so it's a great pleasure to have
Adam buland here from Stanford to talk
about Quantum pseudo entanglement
So Adam got his PhD at MIT and then he
was a postdoc at the Simons Institute
before moving on to Stanford
so his his research is in
in
Quantum complexity Theory Quantum
computation but with a with a definite
view to uh to to the foundations of
physics
and he's done lots of work on random
circuit sampling and Quantum Supremacy
but also also on this also work on
uh you know Quantum pseudor Randomness
and black holes so
um Adam looking forward to your talk
today great yeah thanks so much for
having me so I'll go ahead and uh
share my screen
uh let's see here
wait actually is this uh let's see here
great can you now see my just the slide
yeah
yeah okay great all right yeah so thanks
so much for the uh for the invitation uh
so I'll be talking today about uh some
recent work I had on Quantum pseudo
entanglement
um and this is based on joint work with
Scott Aronson Bill fefferman uh showmake
um
and Jack Joe
so the starting point for this for this
talk is the notion of classical
Randomness So In classical algorithms
Randomness is often viewed as a resource
for classical computation like for
example if you are you know trying to
run the sort of algorithm that involves
hashing to have quick look up for for
some sort of functional search problem
then you might want to do something like
pick a random hash function H from n
Bits to n Bits right but the common
issue that you face in these algorithmic
applications is that you often have
access to only a limited number of truly
random bits like for example you know
describing a truly random hash function
requires exponentially many random bits
you might not have access to that many
bits or that much computation time to
define a truly random function right
so the way that this is usually solved
in classical Computing is via
pseudo-randomeness where the basic idea
is that you can efficiently spoof random
bits with much less Randomness than you
might naively think is required
like more formally the idea is to take a
very small uh random seed s which might
be say a poly logarithmic length and
expand it to an N bit seed an N bit
string are of s in such a way that the
induced Distribution on N bit strings is
indistinguishable in some way from that
of a truly random and bit string right
and the first time you see this this
might seem somewhat counter-intuitive
right like there's very little entropy
in this distribution you know there's
only polylog bits of entropy instead of
n Bits of entropy right so they're only
a very small number of isolated strings
in this ensemble
but nevertheless it's still possible to
construct pseudorandom uh you know
pseudo-random uh generators you know in
in various different sorts of security
guarantees so you know sometimes people
consider pseudor Randomness with respect
to information theoretic forms of
security so this is usually called like
independent distributions you know
these are distributions on n Bits that
look random if you only look at a subset
of K of the bits but if you look at more
of the bits they might have some more
sorts of correlations there
right and there's of course also the
computational form of pseudorandomeness
which is the which is uh ensembles of
random strings are indistinguishable
from truly random strings to any
efficient algorithm right this is the
notion of a pseudorandom generator right
and what's nice about both of these uh
you know types of constructions is that
they use exponentially less Randomness
than than you would think would be
naively required to have at random bits
all right and you know this gives rise
to a large number of applications you
know cryptography and algorithms as well
as in complexity theory in the form of
say de-randomization
now when we move to Quantum algorithms
entanglement plays a similar role as a
resource for Quantum computation for
example we know that entanglement is a
necessary resource you know it's a
necessary ingredient if we want to
achieve a Quantum algorithmic speed up
like in other words if you have a
Quantum computation that doesn't produce
very much entanglement
um it's in in many circumstances easy to
simulate that classically
okay now of course the role of
entanglement and Quantum Computing is
not exactly analogous to the role of
Randomness and classical Computing
because quantum entanglement
um is in some ways a little more rich
and a little more subtle than classical
Randomness like for example we don't
know a way to pull the entanglement out
of a Quantum algorithm in the same way
that we know how to pull the randomness
out of a classical algorithm right
and moreover you know there are many
different types and measures of
entanglement that that one can consider
right
but nevertheless in this work we we try
to ask the following question you know
is it possible in any setting to spoof
entanglement in the same way that
classical pseudorandomeness allows you
to spoof random numbers right and our
main result is that the answer is yes
like it actually is possible to spoof
entanglement uh in the way that that's
somewhat analogous to to classical
pseudorandom uh generators
right so in more detail in this work we
describe a new notion that we call
pseudoentanglement right and what's the
basic idea of pseudoentanglement well at
a high level it's ensembles of
efficiently constructable Quantum States
you know one Ensemble has lots of
entanglements like very high
entanglement another Ensemble with very
low entanglement but these two ensembles
are indistinguishable to any efficient
Quantum algorithm right
and then this work we not only Define
this notion of pseudoentanglement but we
also give the first construction of
pseudoentangled states which which have
an exponential reduction in the amount
of entanglement in other words we can
exponentially you know we can hide an
exponential amount of entanglements with
with our constructions and uh you know
this you know we achieved this reduction
in entanglement in a variety of
different measures so in particular we
give an exponential reduction in the
Schmidt rank so this implies you know
immediately exponential reductions and
you know essentially any other
entanglement measure like vond entropy
or any other sort of entropy you'd like
to consider
okay and of course this this will as
we'll describe this this new
construction is only possible with
through a computational lens like it's
only possible if you take a
computational view of security and our
work is inspired by uh prior paper of
Giorgio and huben which considered a
similar notion and I'll discuss that
more in detail uh later in the talk
okay and just to give you the the punch
line of the talk uh at the beginning in
particular what will show is that the
following sorts of quantum states are
pseudoentangled so they're states that
look like this they're an equal
superposition over all strings and some
subset
where we then apply a random phase f of
x like this is a plus or minus one
random phase to that element of the
subset and in particular we show that if
you choose the set s pseudo randomly and
you choose the binary phases to the
randomly via a pseudo-random function
then we will prove that these states are
are pseudoentangled the basic idea is
that by changing the size of the subset
that you're creating an equal
superposition of this will give us a
knob we can turn to change the
entanglement of these states in the way
that we'll be able to hide from any
polytime Observer
moreover we'll also show that these
states are pseudo-random states that has
to say they're also indistinguishable
from the from our random States as well
right
and a little leader talk I'll describe
some new applications of this new
construction uh namely to some new
property testing bounds for matrix
product States uh and new other sorts of
property testing bounds to learning
Schmidt rank uh and even some
applications to quantum gravity as well
great so to understand our construction
it's helpful to start with a bit of
background uh on the notion of quantum
pseudo-randomness right
so a common goal in Quantum algorithms
is to spoof the hard measure on States
or unitaries that's to say we want to
create some Ensemble of of unitaries or
states that that is indistinguishable in
some ways from the heart measure okay so
why is this interesting well it turns
out that you know it's a very common
algorithmic technique to consider taking
har averages in the course of your
algorithm like some examples of this are
you know randomized benchmarking where
you take car averages to uh to diagnose
errors on the quantum computer or
efficient Shadow tomography protocols
where you want to ideally measure your
system in some different hard random
bases and collect statistics on it and
in order to to reproduce some
measurement statistics of the state
right but the common issue in these
applications is that you know you cannot
efficiently generate hard random States
or unitaries and pulling in real time
right there is a standard counting
argument that says if you want to create
an end cubet hard random State this is a
this is a task that requires two to the
end uh the local Gates on your Quantum
device
so the common solution is to uh find
different ways of efficiently spoofing
the hard measure so more formally you
create ensembles of what are called
pseudo-random Quantum states which have
very short Quantum circuits but are
nevertheless indistinguishable from our
random States in a certain sense
so the most common way of creating kind
of quantum forms of pseudo-randomness is
to create information theoretic forms of
pseudorandomeness and these are called t
designs so more formally a Quantum T
design is an ensemble of quantum states
such that no algorithm can distinguish T
copies of a random state from The
Ensemble from T copies of a horrendum
state right so there is alternative
definition which says that you know it's
equivalent to saying that you match the
first T moments of the hard measure
right so this is an information
theoretic form of pseudorandomness and
it has many important applications you
know in in randomized benchmarking
efficient Shadow tomography
um etc etc
and what's nice about Quantum P designs
is that there exists many efficient
constructions of T designs like for
example we know that random Clifford
circuits are a three design or you know
sufficiently deep random circuits are
are T designs you know that there's a
rich literature exploring how to create
efficient forms of information theoretic
quantum pseudo-randomeness
that's
but there's an alternative way of
thinking about Quantum pseudo Randomness
which is a little more natural from the
computer science lens which is to
consider a form of computational
pseudorandomness right that is to say to
consider ensembles of efficiently
preferable Quantum states that are
nevertheless indistinguishable to from
hard random states by any efficient
Quantum algorithm all right so this is a
notion that was first defined by G Leo
and song in 2018
and since then we found a wide number of
applications of of computational pseudor
Randomness in the quantum setting as
well
so of course if you're making a
computational security guarantee you're
going to have to make some sort of
computational assumption in order to get
these states but what G Leo and song
said is show this that this actually
requires only very mild cryptographic uh
assumptions namely that there exists
some sort of one-way function that's
secure against Quantum attack
right
so this is a really different notion of
pseudo-randomness than the usual notion
of a unitary T design right so in one
sense you might think that this notion
of computational pseudorandomness is
just a weaker notion than the t design
right so like if you compare the
security guarantee of a t design versus
the security guarantee of a
computational pseudorandom state you
know the security guarantee of the
computational pseudor randomness is
weaker right it's just saying no
efficient algorithm can distinguish
these ensembles of States whereas for T
designs that say no algorithm period
could could distinguish these states
but it turns out you can actually get
something a little stronger out of
computational pseudo-randomness which is
that you can actually show that you can
actually get Security even against
arbitrary polynomial number of copies of
the state which is not possible with a t
design like with the T design once you
fix your T design you know T copies of
the state are information theoretically
distinguishable indistinguishable from
random but not necessarily t plus one
copies right so you're kind of locked in
on the number of copies there
okay
so in this work one question that we ask
is what is the relationship between
Quantum pseudo-randomness and
entanglement
right so if you look at a typical har
random state
and you divide it on n qubits and you
divide it into the entanglement entropy
that you have between the left and over
two qubits and the right and there are
over two qubits is nearly maximal and in
fact you know the maximum possible value
is n over two you can show that the the
the entanglement entropy is typically n
over to minus some very small constant
right
now similarly you can show that t
designs are also maximally entangled as
well for any T greater than they're
equal to two so actually a Quantum T
design while you know it can give you a
big savings in terms of say circuit
complexity it does not give you any
savings in terms of entanglement right
so so T designs are actually are also
maximally entangled
so what about if you have
computationally pseudo-random States
right well in this in the case of
computational pseudo-randomeness the
only thing we knew about pseudor
Randomness and entanglement prior to our
work was a a lower bound on how much
entanglement pseudo-random states have
to have and that lower bound was is just
that they have to have a super
logarithmic amount of entanglement
entropy across most cuts of the state
right so you can see that there's an
exponential gap between how much
entanglement there is in the har random
State and how much entanglement we know
we knew that we needed in order to have
a computational form of pseudorandomness
right so a natural question to ask is
you know if you have computationally
pseudo-random States you know where do
they lie in the Spectrum like can you
make pseudo-random states that have you
know only say log squared and
entanglement entropy right like is it
even possible for for this sort of
object to exist
right
and our main result in this language is
that surprisingly yes it is actually
possible to construct computationally
pseudo-random States uh with very low
amounts of entanglement which actually
fully saturate this JLS lower bound
right so more formally what we show is
something like this we show that there
exists ensembles of pseudo-random states
where if you take any cut of the state
right like any division of of the state
into two subsets of qubits and you look
at the entanglement entropy across that
cut that entanglement entropy can be as
low as merely poly logarithmic and N
right so that is to say pseudo-random
states can have you know computationally
pseudo random states can have
exponentially less entanglement than
than T designs
right so this is something that's not
possible in an information theoretic
setting you you have to take a
computational lens in order to achieve
something like this
right and what's nice about our
construction is that it only relies on
standard cryptographic assumptions
namely there that there is a one-way
function uh secure against Quantum
attack
and moreover we can also make our pseudo
Randomness kind of tunable like we can
set the entanglement and entropy across
any cut to any function that you like uh
as long as it's strictly between log n
and n right so there's nothing special
about log Square then in our
construction like you can actually set
the entanglement type anywhere on the
spectrum that that you like you know
within the kind of permissible
boundaries of of computational
pseudo-randomness
okay so this in some ways looks like
classical pseudorandomness right like in
class goes through the randomness you're
asking how much entropy do you need in a
classical probability distribution to
mimic the uniform distributions right
classical pseudorandomness says well you
know only poly logarithmically many bits
of entropy are needed uh under classical
cryptographic assumptions
right and you know our work is getting a
similar exponential Gap but for
entanglement entropy instead of the
usual notion of of you know Shannon
entropy for for random bits
of course there's an important caveat
here that distinguishes our results from
classical pseudo Randomness which is
that you know uh we're we're only
spoofing the entanglement of certain
families of quantum States
um yeah you know so this doesn't have
the same application for you know like
like prgs have for de-randomization but
it's very similar in spirit in the terms
of achieving this exponential reduction
in some measure so I think it you know
the way the thing of it is like it's
this first point of exploration of the
space of what sorts of entanglement you
you can efficiently spoof
all right great
so I'm going to discuss some
applications of our result uh later in
the talk
um but to start with I'm going to give
you a uh first I'm going to give a proof
sketch of how it's even possible to
create these sorts of states that have
very low entanglement and yet
nevertheless look like hard random
States
right
so the starting point for our
construction is the phase state
pseudo-random state construction of G
Leo and song
um and uh a variant of which was later
proved pseudorandom by breakersky and
schmueling
so in particular we consider states of
the following form so let's consider
states that are an equal superposition
over all strings
where in each for each you know uh for
each basis Vector of the superposition
we will apply a pseudo-random plus or
minus one phase to the state
so the main result of these prior Works
was that these states are already a a
computational you know pseudo-random
State Ensemble or a PRS assuming that
your your your phases are are a Quantum
secure are given by some Quantum secure
pseudo-random function
right so like what what why are these a
a a computational like pseudo-random
State well first of all it's easy to see
that uh it's Rel it's very easy to
prepare these states right like uh you
know if you want to prepare the state
all you need to do is first have them
add all your qubits to create an equal
superposition over strings
and then apply your pseudorandom
function in superposition to the states
right as a phase Oracle so these are
manifestly easy to produce
uh so the more the more interesting
Direction was that they showed us that
you know if you didn't know the secret
key of your prf then no efficient
Quantum algorithm can distinguish
polynomially many copies of these random
face States from polymer polynomially
many copies of a high random state so
more formally any efficient Quantum
algorithm a has a negligible you know
probability of distinguishing a state
from this Ensemble versus a state from
the har on some right and that was the
main result of these prior Works was to
establish this first you know this first
pseudo-random uh State Construction
okay
so in our construction you know okay if
you look at this construction you know
it's not really obvious what the
entanglement entropy of this
construction might be right like uh like
uh the the entanglement entropy you can
relate it in some way to uh some Matrix
defined based on the entries of the
pseudorandom function but uh but you
know the entanglement properties of of
this state are not are not directly
related to the pseudo-randomeness
property of the function so it's not
immediately clear how these states are
related to entanglement right
so in order to create low entanglement
pseudo-random States we create a
different version of this construction
which is a new pseudo-random state
construction that we call the subset
phase State Construction
right so what's the basic idea we
consider some states that we call subset
phase States
which look like the the the JLS uh
pseudo-random State Construction
but instead of being supported on all
embed strings our states are instead
only supported on a subset s of the
n-bit strings right uh So within that
subset we still apply pseudo-random
phases to the state
but the subset itself you know say what
might be chosen in in some sort of
random or pseudo-random fashion that
that we'll describe shortly
all right so our again the phases are
just you know
similar to JLS they're just given by
some Quantum secure pseudo-random
function
right
so why are these phase States you know
nice to look at when you're considering
entanglement well a nice thing is that
if your states are only supported on the
subset of basis strings of sides you
know Norm of s then clearly the Schmidt
rank of the state across any cut is
automatically less than or equal to the
number of states in your superposition
right so in other words the size of the
subset the size of the support of these
subset phase States naturally is an
upper bound on the amount of
entanglement in these states
right
so this is closely related you may have
seen some states like this before in
Quantum information like you know there
are a lot of places where a closely
related construction has been considered
called Pure you know just subset States
so these are states where you consider
an equal superposition over all elements
uh in the subset without any phases you
know these have been studied many places
like for example Quantum money uh
variants of qma based on subset States
uh etc etc in fact they were even
previously suggested as a potential
pseudorandom State construction by G Leo
and song
um but for various technical reasons
I'll describe later uh you know we we
end up adding the phases to these states
so these are kind of you know the states
we're considering are somewhere between
subset States and the random face State
constructions right
okay
and the main result of our work is we
show that pseudo-random subset States
uh are suit are indeed pseudo random
even when they have really really small
subset sizes that's to say even when the
subset sizes say nearly super polynomial
and N right which is exponentially
smaller than the size the subset could
be right
so more formally what we show is the
following result right if you have any
function f of n that's between log n and
n
then if you create subset face states
with pseudo-random subsets of size 2 to
the F of n
and pseudo-random phases then these are
a a computationally secure pseudo-random
State construction right so by dialing
the size of the subsets we consider we
can create you know any amount of
tanglements we want right and you know
what's nice about this is that the
entanglement entropy of these states is
low across any cut of the state
simultaneously
right so as you know it's immediately
core Larry this means that there exists
computationally secure prs's with in
tingling entropy F of n across every
single cut of the State uh at the same
time
right and uh moreover we can also give a
lower bound on the entanglement entropy
to you know of Omega F of n as well so
like we can achieve a very you know we
can make this entanglement tunable in
the sense by by increasing the subset
size and by by playing some games with
with how we pick the pseudorandom
function that's as well I will get into
details of of this lower bound but in
the rest of talk I'm just going to focus
on establishing the entanglement upper
bound since I think that that that
that's the more interesting Direction
here
okay so why are random subset face
States a pseudo-random States right so
if we want to establish this we need to
prove two facts first is that it's easy
to construct these states right and
secondly we need to show that they're
computationally indistinguishable from
our random States okay
so proving that these states are easy to
construct is relatively straightforward
right so let's say we want to prepare
some subset state right where we have
some subset in mind s and some you know
some uh pseudo random function f
uh and let's let's just assume that the
subset that we're we're considering is a
size that's a power of two okay
well the basic idea is that in order to
prepare the state you can first prepare
you know it's very easy to prepare a
superposition over some fixed subset
right so for example if I take my n
qubits starting in all zeros and I just
had a marked the first F of n qubits of
the state you know this prepares an
equal superposition of some subset of
states it just happens to be a very
simple to describe subset right it's all
the strings that have zeros on the last
n minus F of n Bits And and are every
possible string on the first F of n Bits
right so it's very easy to prepare a
fixed subset state
yeah so in order to turn this into a
pseudo randomly chosen subset State you
know we we need to randomize the subset
and the basically the basic way that you
can do this is by applying uh what's
called a pseudo-random permutation pi to
the subset in the manner that's called
an In-Place application that's to say we
need some way of applying this
permutation Pi directly to the register
right like that that you know Pi takes
some string Y and it outputs Pi of Y uh
in place right so this is applying a
literal permutation of the computational
basis States right if we can do that for
a pseudo-random permutation Pi then this
allows us to prepare an equal
superposition over a pseudo-random
subset right where our subset s is
defined as the image of these strings y
followed by zeros under under the
pseudorandom permutation right
so of course in order to do less you
know there is a little caveat like uh in
order to apply this permutation in place
uh you need to be able you know there
there are some standard tricks in
reversible Computing that say you can do
this if you can efficiently invert the
PRP as well and it turns out it it is
easily possible to do this with various
you know it's kind of standard tricks
from reversible Computing right it's
it's really using the fact that you know
the secret key that allows you to invert
the permutation basically just by by
uncomputing and and running it backwards
right
and then you know to you know you know
so now we're almost there like we have a
superposition over the pseudo-random
subset all we're missing is the phases
right so in order to to add the phases
to the stage we now just apply our
pseudo-random function in in
superposition just like was done in in
in the JLS construction right so these
states are kind of manifestly easy to
prepare if the subsets are pseudo-random
and the phases are pseudoring
great so the more difficult part of the
proof is to show that these
pseudo-random subset face states are
indistinguishable from hard random
States right so in order to prove this
computationally in distinguishability
property uh the proof follows two steps
okay so in the first step we show that
if our chosen phases and our chosen
subsets were truly random then then the
states that we produce would be
statistically indistinguishable from
harm
right so in other words if if your
subset s was a truly random you know one
of the different quasi-polynally sized
subsets of of two to the N strings then
you would actually have prepared
something that is statistically close or
information theoretically close to to
the hard measure right
and the second step of the proof we then
just replace all of the true Randomness
that we used in in the truly random
subset phase State and we just replace
it with pseudorandomeness right and it
then immediately follows that you know
that this our pseudo random phase phase
subset states are computationally
indistinguishable from the truly random
ones right and this implies that you're
computationally in the central from harm
by a hybrid argument right we're just
considering one intermediate hybrid
right the hybrid is truly random uh
subset face States right
so these are the two things that that we
need to show right uh and you know the
the more difficult one of these to show
is this first fact which is that if the
phases and subsets were truly random
that that that that these states would
be statistically close to Har right and
I'll give you a very brief sketch of of
how you show this uh and the proof uses
a lot of nice representation Theory uh
that that that that that that uh that
I'm happy to give like a a high level
picture of right
okay so let's say our goal now is to try
to show that truly random subset face
states are close and Trace distance to
the hard measure right
so how are we going to show this well it
turns out that the density Matrix of a
unknown har random state has a very nice
interpretation right it's actually just
proportional to a projector onto the
symmetric Subspace of these systems
right so in other words if we take a
high random State Phi right
and we consider taking T copies of that
Phi and we look at that you know what is
the density Matrix that we obtain of
that state that density Matrix is just
equal to some projector Pi onto the
symmetric Subspace of of of
n-dimensional systems that you get from
permuting you know and the the symmetric
subface refers to permuting the two
different copies right so it's just
proportional up to less projector up to
some normalization
right so why is this true this actually
comes from some well-known facts from
sure while Duality like if you look at
the set of symmetries of this density
Matrix you know it has two kind of
natural symmetries like one symmetry is
that you know because the hard measure
is invariant and they're applying any uh
you know capital N dimensional unitary
to it right then uh you know applying
the same unitary to each state you know
to each copy preserves this density
Matrix
and similarly because we're taking tea
copies of the same state it's also
invariant under permuting the action of
permuting these two different copies and
effectively What's Happening Here is
that when we're drawing a hard random
State we're kind of already building in
this average over the unitary group so
all that's left in this state is the
projector onto the you know the
symmetric subspaces the the subspaces
that are preserved by by the symmetric
group
right
okay great so this is just kind of a a
well-known fact uh that that's that's
coming from representation Theory
right
all right great so now when it comes to
you know uh you know okay so the second
fact that that we're going to use in
this construction is that you know if
you take random phase States it turns
out that random face states are very
close to the projector onto the
symmetric Subspace so this was actually
at the heart of G Leo and song and
burkurski and shulele's prior proof of
of the pseudo-randomness of of uh random
face dates like they follow the similar
hybrid argument where they said you know
let's first consider truly random face
dates and they showed by direct
calculation that truly random face
states are actually close in Trace
distance to our random States right so
we can just use this lever kind of
directly from their work
right and what this means is that you
know if you just take their levels and
you import them into our context
you end up getting a very similar Lemma
for random subsets based states that
says something like this
so let me parse this so this is a lot of
loop notation so let me parse this
equation we're saying like
let's say you fix a subset s
of of basis States and now you consider
random subset face states where you draw
our phase function f truly randomly
right
then you can show using the techniques
in these papers that that uh the trace
distance between this state and the
projector onto the symmetric Subspace
confined just to the to that subset s of
basis States is very small it's
something it's related it's polynomial
in the number of copies T and it's
inverse uh you know and you pick up a
factor of of one over the size of the
subset that that you're considering
right so this is just saying we just
take their Lemma and import it uh to to
the case of a fixed subset s
then you know the projector onto the
symmetric space of that subset it's a
pretty good standard for for for our for
our random subset phase States right
all right so what this means is that you
know if we want to show our random face
subset states are close to Har our
question just boils down to studying
these different projectors right like
one like our States look something like
this they're like a projector onto
symmetric subsets of of of S elements
where we take an expectation
over the choice of subsets right versus
hard random states which is considering
the projector onto all of the the
symmetric Subspace on all of the N basis
States at the same time right so our
entire you know our entire problem
basically boils down to asking you know
how close are these two different the
these these two different states one is
a projector the other is some sort of
average over projectors where where you
average over the subsets
and the main technical part of our
result is a new calculation and and that
we we show that these states are
actually very close in Trace distance
right actually the distance between you
know
the the relevant symmetric projectors
related to our state versus those of a
high random state is something like uh
order of the number of copies squared
divided by the size of the subsets that
we're considering right
great
so and the proof of this is a bit
complicated it uses this type
enumeration that method of uh ananta at
all who had a simplification of this
this Trace distance calculation from uh
brakersky shulele and so so see our
archive version if you want to see kind
of the full details of the proof but
it's really all about you know doing
this phrase distance calculation very
carefully
great so if we now put this together
right like we showed that our random
subset face states are close to these
projectors and these projectors are then
close to hard random States we get the
following statement by the triangle and
the quality we get that the trace
distance between truly random subset
face States and heart random States is
upper bounded by this quantity it's you
know the number of coffees squared over
the size of the support of our subset
right
and this immediately give us gives us
what we want right this is a very strong
lower bound right and this is a very
strong upper bound because it's saying
that as long as you choose the size of
your subsets to be super polynomially
sized then this Trace distance is an
inverse super polynomial quantity right
so it's saying that you can get away
with relatively large sorry relatively
small subsets compared to what you might
think you might need uh to to to achieve
to achieve pseudor randomness
all right
great and once we achieve this uh this
uh statistical calculation like this
Upward Bound on the trace distance
between truly random subset face States
and horror this immediately tells us
that pseudorandom subset face states are
computationally indistinguishable from
har by a straightforward hybrid argument
right so you know we just showed that
our random states are information
theoretically close to truly random
subset-phase States
well almost by the definition of
pseudorandomness this means that our
pseudo-random subset-faced states are
computationally indistinguishable from
from the truly random subset phase
States so if we just put these together
you know this means that our
pseudo-random subset phase states have
to be computationally indistinguishable
from hard random states which is the
desired fact that that we wanted to show
and the fact that we can get low
entanglement here is coming from the
fact that we can push our subset sizes
to be you know relatively small
great now for those of you who have seen
uh a prior version of this talk or prior
version of this paper you might have
noticed that we actually switched
pseudo-random State constructions
compared to our old archive V1 right
actually in in our original construction
uh that we talked about at qip uh of
what we showed is that there are
pseudo-random states which have low
entanglement across a single cut of the
state using the binary phase State
construction of Prior works right so our
prior construction used the original PRS
constructions right
um so what what why did we switch away
for for from from that from the original
binary face State Construction
well it turns out that it is possible to
generalize our prior construction with
low entanglement slightly in the
direction of achieving lower
entanglement across more cuts like uh
you you can actually show that you could
can obtain something called pseudo 1D
area law pseudo-random states using our
old construction
um by some proof that was like you had
to like repeatedly squash down the
entanglement across many different cuts
of the state
um we include the details in the
appendix uh of our new version that if
you're if you're interested uh I'll
discuss this pseudo 1D area law a little
bit later in the talk so I'm only giving
it at a high level here
but you know the issue is that these
prior this this construction was quite
complicated and it didn't generalize it
it didn't seem to generalize further to
handle more sorts of cuts of a stage
right so our new subset face State
construction is actually kind of much
nicer than our prior construction like
because we're able to achieve now low
entanglement across all Cuts
simultaneously and the proof of this
result is much simpler
um that that that that that than it is
if you try to do some some similar
things uh with with standard standard
binary face dates and and it gives you a
stronger result because it achieves all
Cuts uh at the same time
okay great so uh
yeah so in some sense you know we we've
achieved this goal of defining some sort
of pseudo entanglement right so you know
our work is arguing that in some ways
entanglement is not a feelable or
polynomially time testable property of
of a Quantum system right we're showing
that given polynomially many copies of
an encube at State you can't efficiently
tell if it's highly entangled or not
and you know this this is what you know
inspired us to give this new definition
of pseudo entanglement right which is
our ensembles of states which are easy
to construct have very different
entanglements and nevertheless no
algorithms can efficiently uh the
distinguish between them
all right so uh uh you know we also give
a formal definition of of of of this
this notion uh as my time is running
quite short I might skip through the the
formal definition and point you to the
paper if you're interested but it's kind
of it's exactly what you would expect
it's two ensembles of states that are
you know it's easy to make them they
have different entanglement structures
um but but they're computationally
indistinguishable from one another uh in
some way right
so you know in in our language uh you
know I mentioned there is this nice
prior work of Giorgio and huben that
inspired uh our our definition of
pseudoentanglement so uh in particular
what this prior work had achieved is
they showed that if lwe is hard for
quantum computers then there's a way to
hide a constant number of bits of
entanglement uh the in the state like
you can create some states which have n
Bits of entanglement entropy and another
Ensemble of states with n minus order
one bits of entanglement entropy uh
where no efficient Quantum algorithm can
distinguish between the two right
and our result is is showing something
very similar but with a much larger Gap
in entanglement entropy right so we're
showing that you can go from
entanglement n to say something like
entanglement log Square then and still
hide this hide you know and you you can
hide now an exponential amount of
entanglement entropy while also being a
pseudo-random state and moreover while
doing it across all you know followed by
while reducing the entanglement across
all cuts of the State uh at the same
time
okay so with my remaining kind of five
or five five to ten minutes I'll I'll I
want to briefly discuss some sort of
applications of of our results right so
you know where the finding this new
notion of pseudo entanglement
um and you know we're we hope that these
are just kind of the tip of the iceberg
and that uh one will eventually find
more more applications of this notion in
in analogous way to the fact that uh
pseudorandomness has found the large
number of applications in classical
Computing right but let me give one
application of our result uh in in
detail and then kind of sketch a few
others right so it turns out that our
new pseudoentanglement result uh implies
uh a new lower Bound for a problem
called uh matrix product State Testing
or MPS testing
okay so what is this problem so matrix
product states are an extremely useful
subset of quantum States that's useful
for studying Quantum simulation and
Quantum hamiltonian complexity and
they're used many places in Quantum
information
and the reason that they're so useful is
that matrix product states are a subset
of quantum states that are very easy to
describe like they admit they have
polynomial description complexity and
moreover uh it's also possible to
efficiently compute with this
description of States as well
right so a matrix product stay is
parameterized by something called the
bond Dimension k
which in some sense uh it formally it's
equal to the size of some sort of tensor
that you place at each cudit of the
state
right and kind of what happens is as you
increase the bond Dimension that matrix
product states end up describing a
larger and larger family of a larger and
larger subset of quantum States right
and the you know one reason that matrix
product states have been so useful is
that they naturally obey something
that's called an area law which is to
say if you place your qubits on on the
line right and you consider you know
making a partition of your qubits into
two different subsets say the middle
three qubits versus the outer qubits
right let's call the reduced density
Matrix on that state row
then you can show that for any matrix
product State the entanglement entropy
of rho is up or bounded by the area of
the cut in other words the number of
edges of the 1D line that you cut with
your partition times the log of your
bond Dimension k
right
okay
and you know there's a Converse to this
theorem as well which is that any state
that has a 1D area law also has a matrix
product State as well uh I know that
this is shown in this uh Vidal work uh
though it it it it it it might happen
earlier uh uh predecessor as well
okay so the problem of matrix product
State Testing is to ask the following
question given an unknown state
um then is this unknown State either an
N cubits K Bond Dimension MPS
or is it far in Trace distance from any
such NPS right so this is a a property
testing like problem you're asking does
the state that you're given have the
property of being a matrix product state
or being very far from a matrix product
state
right so uh relatively little was known
about this property testing result until
very recently so in particular uh last
year uh
solomonifar and Wright showed that MPS
testing requires at least square root n
copies of the State uh in an information
theoretic setting like in other words
there exists some states they may or may
not be efficient to prepare uh
uh such that testing of these states are
an MPS or not is is actually very
difficult uh even when the bond
Dimension K is is very low
right
now in immediate corollary part result
is actually to show a complementary
bound to this to this recent uh NPS
testing down in particular a corollary
of of our new single entanglement result
is that NPS testing requires at least K
to the one-half copies of the state
either information theoretically or
computationally right so this is saying
something very different right the prior
bound said that NPS testing is hard even
with a low Bond Dimension as you scale
the number of qubits
our result is saying something different
if you take mps's and you consider
increasing the bond dimension of those
states to bigger and bigger polynomials
or maybe even super polynomial size the
problem of MPS testing gets harder and
harder in fact it scales polynomially
with with the bond Dimension that that
you choose and in fact our you know our
our bound even holds in testing MPS
States versus hard random States right
so what what what's the connection here
well remember that our states have very
low entanglement entropy across any cut
of the state
that actually immediately implies that
our state have obeyed something called a
a pseudo-area law entanglement in 1D
right because you know area law is just
saying you have low entanglement for
certain Cuts well we have low
entanglement for all cuts at the same
time so of course we have won the area
law entanglement
right you know how big is you know so
since our states had area law
entanglement this means our states also
have some MPS description
with some Bond Dimension that scales
with the size of our subsets s right so
our Trace distance calculation actually
immediately gives you the desired
information theoretic bound on on MPS
testing just by considering you know our
result has shown it's hard to tell these
particular MPS dates from our random
States right and we can do this either
in an information theoretic setting or
in a computational setting
okay we have a few other applications
and property testing like to testing
Schmidt rank
um and uh some no-go results to for
efficient distillation uh and I don't
have time to talk about these so I'll
point you to the paper to see these
and finally I want to end with a little
more speculative note which is that you
know we think that these these uh our
new pseudoentanglement constructions
might have something interesting to say
about the complexity of of quantum
gravity and the ads CFT correspondence
so the ads CFT correspondence is this
just this conjectured Duality between a
quantum gravity Theory like this object
that theoretical physicists have been
trying to construct for decades
and a simpler much simpler quantum
mechanical system called the conformal
field Theory which lives on the boundary
of that theory
and the conjecture is that there's some
dictionary map which is some sort of
homomorphism between these two theories
that Maps States in one Theory to States
and the other Theory and operators in
one Theory two operators and the other
Theory right so this is a really
interesting thing because it's saying
you know if you want to study quantum
gravity one way you might be able to do
it is by studying this much simpler
quantum mechanical system through this
homomorphism
right and the major entanglement of uh
of this ads EFT correspondence is it's
believed that the entanglement
properties of the quantum mechanical
Theory
correspond to geometrical properties of
the quantum gravity Theory like in other
words the entanglement of the quantum
states that sit on the right hand side
of this Duality is directly related
to to the the the the the
geometry of you know of of the
einsteinian metric which describes the
space time of your quantum gravity
Theory
and our result is saying at a high level
that entanglement uh is something that's
very difficult to feel or to observe to
bounded polynomial time observers right
but on the other hand you know the
geometry of of a gravitational metric
feels like something that should be
manifestly easy to compute right it
feels like something you know if you
were in the space time you should be
able to just kind of take it take out
some ruler and you'll measure a certain
distances and ads CFT is saying those
distances are connected to entanglement
okay
so this said something very interesting
about quantum gravity because if it's
saying that you know if the
corresponding geometry
uh is is something that's efficiently
measurable then that's saying that this
adscft dictionary that Maps between the
two theories has to be doing something
that is exponentially complex right
because it's taking something that's
very hard to observe you know like
entanglement entropies and making it
something that's very easy to observe
like the length of sub-giodesics in in
some gravitational Theory and you know
uh this was actually indeed part of
Giorgio and hoban's motivation for this
work and you know there is a prior paper
of myself and Bill feferman and and
Umesh vazarani that was arguing that
that something like this might might
occur already right but
if if we were able to make this
connection more rigorous it would then
end up saying that the the
complexity you know the the high
complexity of quantum gravity is coming
from a very fundamental property of the
correspondence rather than some of the
particular elements that that we used in
the the original paper to try to argue
for hardness of the dictionary so I
think this is a really interesting kind
of potential application uh of our
results that I'm looking forward to
discussing more uh momentarily
all right so let me wrap up now so what
have we seen in this talk you know we
Define this new notion called
pseudoentanglement and we showed that
you can efficiently spoof very entangled
Quantum states with relatively little
entanglements you know even with states
that have low entanglement across all
cuts of the state simultaneously and I
think you know there are a large number
of open problems here that that I I I I
I think are are really interesting like
you know one of the ways we made
progress on this construction was by
giving a new pseudorandom state
construction based on these subset
States right so I I think there are
really interesting questions to ask you
if if there are other sorts of PRS
constructions lying out there they might
have even different sorts of
entanglement properties
right uh second I think there's a lot of
uh potential for applications of these
sorts of ideas to physics like for
example our states have this sort of
like 1D pseudo area law entanglement and
in condensed matter Theory one often
Associates things like area law
entanglement with say uh different
phases of of quantum matter right so
there might be some potential
applications to you know maybe arguing
that it might be hard to learn certain
phases of matter
um yeah I I think that could be a really
interesting direction as well as trying
to flush out some of these ideas uh
about trying to connect our states with
uh with quantum gravity like for example
can you mix through the random states
that have entanglement structures that
look like the states that appear in
quantum gravity actually in some sense
in our construction we overshot like uh
like we just cut our entangled across
all Cuts way down to almost nothing but
the state star can usually present in
these quantum gravity theories have like
a kind of area law or super area law but
sub volume law entanglement structure so
to answer this question we would
actually need to dial up the integral
events of pseudo-random states right
rather than dial it down
finally you know there's a nice question
of if we can create some new sort of
like cryptographic Primitives out of
these these sorts of States you know
I've been giving a lot of no-go results
for applications but there are some
natural questions of having low
entanglement prses you might might
enable some new sorts of applications
and of course there's a question of if
we can make a more near-term
implementable version of these states at
the moment they're they're they're
they're constructed with General one-way
functions so they're they're not
um it's it's not obvious that these
would be amenable to this device
all right thanks thanks so much for your
time and thanks for your Indulgence for
going a few minutes over
great thank you thanks Adam
um great talk so
um
uh are there any questions before we
move to the panel
oh yeah novet uh hi uh can you hear me
how's it going
good thanks uh great talk um so I I was
wondering for this matrix product states
which can be distinguished from Super
highly intended states too you know how
these states actually look like like
what is the form of these questions
that's a great question uh I don't know
what they look like uh and uh the the
thing that I think is challenging like
okay there is some induced Distribution
on them right because an MPS exists so
given our safety yeah as you're saying
like you can in principle convert them
to nps's but I I have no idea what what
that distribution looks like and uh it I
I would guess it's not a natural
distribution
um just because we we initially tried
making sorts of pseudo-random States out
of things like random mps's or random
peps but they turned out not not to be
good candidates for reasons we I can
discuss more if you're interested uh so
yeah it might be some it's some very
weird distribution of nps's I think
would be induced okay thanks
uh there's a there's a question in the Q
a balloon I'll allowed to talk and ask
the question directly
so do you want to go ahead
hi um I'm wondering
um like whether there is a simpler
construction of pseudo entanglement that
uses like just pseudo entropy instead of
using uh some
variant of the random States so for
example you can consider a prg and then
like its output will have Channel very
low channel entropy which means that if
you look at the purified picture it will
also have low
um
entanglement entropy as well right so
within this that gives a more simple
that's a great question so the idea
would be something like uh you take the
pseudo-random phase State construction
and then instead of picking the key
uniformly at random you then uh no wait
wait sorry I've I've I've
yeah I I
I'm I'm not sure immediately uh
yeah that's a good question uh
it's not immediately clear because the
uh
yeah okay if you take a pseudo-random
state
and then you just replace the key with
the output of a prg or something like
that no no no
um it should be indistinguishable but
that doesn't translate to low
entanglements right so I I think your
idea is something else like can you say
it again sorry yeah my idea is that you
take
um a prg
you pick some random input and then you
run the prg and then you look at the
entropy of the output
then you will have like essentially very
low channel entropy and therefore it
will also have low entanglement entropy
how do you turn the prg into a Quantum
state so if you just put if you use the
prg to describe the like phases of the
state the exponential no no no there's
nothing yeah actually I want when I'm
like the only Quantum part of this is
just a
uh like the the import generation like
you you prepare this is a distribution
on classical like your strings are just
classical strings exactly
well our statement is that any element
of The Ensemble oh I see so those
strings always have low entanglement
um yeah I don't think so I don't see how
this works we we might need to take this
offline or or I I'd be happy to discuss
further so so Adam maybe this is this is
along the lines of the GLS conjecture
about
um wouldn't this be uh oh yeah which is
which is the superposition of a
pseudorandom strings
oh oh just a superposition over
pseudo-random strings
it seems right now like this
yeah if you took an equal superposition
over pseudo-random strings you know that
would be basically our construction
without the phases right so it would be
simpler and uh yeah it's a great
question yeah JLS constructured
conjectured you might be able to make
something like this work uh uh
in principle there's some really hard
Trace distance calculation you could do
uh that if you could if you could
perform it uh like show the trace
distance between random subset States
and hard random States is is is you know
inverse super polynomially small like if
you could do that then then then you you
would immediately get I think the result
that you're looking for uh but uh yeah
that that
that that's a great open problem and we
don't know yet if if that's true or not
so yeah like just do random subset
States already work
um
Andrew I guess um
I wasn't sure if I should save it for
the panel but um so for these random
subset States if you're only interested
in showing pseudoentanglement but not
pseudorandomness
um would you be able to do that because
as I understand it from your
construction the problem was not being
able to show pseudor Randomness without
adding the phases but if you only want
this like tunable that's a great
question because then you're you're
never trying to connect it to the
symmetric Subspace on everything you're
only talking about two different
averages over different subspaces uh
right yeah that's a great question
um
yeah I don't know like it okay it's not
uh
you know the phases were very important
for us for turning the question into a
question about projector onto any
symmetric subspaces
at all right because that's what
connects you to our random States
um so yeah yeah it's a great question
you you you you you might be able to do
that but I I I don't know if it works
off the top of my head yeah
it's I there would be some sort of
representation Theory calculation you
could do because there are symmetries of
the state
but it's a different symmetry group so
uh yeah it might boil down to some some
question like that
right thanks
okay let's see if there's a question
from the uh let me let me allow Ileana
to talk
you want to go ahead
yeah do you hear me
yeah
sorry it's uh near actually
and so I have a question
um if you replace the PRP by just having
a x and then a kid PRS
with x
could that work
and then instead of fusing a PRP we only
use a prf
yes oh you're asking if if I could
replace the pr sorry could can you
elaborate again how you would place the
PRP with the prf
yeah instead of calculating a pie of x
uh has X comma some drf of x
which also gets you a random subset
yeah
um
I think you would end up with high
entropy wouldn't you
if you if you keep X there
it's I still
not high like exit still of the
Omega log n size
I see so you would just say uh oh you
had these strings y zero you just
replaced the zero with some
TRG of X or something like that I'm
sorry sorry
or something like so you you keep the
initial subset
um yeah I think that would probably work
yeah that's it yeah that's interesting
suggestion I'll Think Through the
details but my initial guess is that
that that that would work we just want
the subset to be pseudo random we don't
really care like you you're correct we
aren't using like all of the Power of a
PRP here right we're just applying
something once right
yeah
so yeah yeah like we're only using it as
as a way of defining you know the image
of Y zero to the N minus F of n is is
our pseudo random set if that's all
we're using then yeah that's a great so
maybe we can just replace it with the
prf
yeah thanks thank you
thanks
okay so um Adam would you like to stop
sharing your slides so we can push it to
the panel
okay great so um
let's see let's um so we have a we have
a fantastic panel uh today
um so
um let me introduce the panelists uh we
have uh Neta engelhardt from MIT
um she's one of the co-winners of the
New Horizons prize for her uh for
um her work on
um uh leading to the resolution of the
black hole information Paradox so they
uh
um very appropriate for this connection
to uh between between entanglement and
and black holes uh we have uh Andrew
Giorgio from this from channels uh
Chalmers University in Sweden so uh
Andrew works on
on um
on all aspects of of
uh Quantum and crypto and you know as
you heard from Adam he he uh he did this
work uh on pseudo entanglement or uh you
know uh exploring entanglement and and
cryptographic instructions
and then we have yikai Liu from
University of Maryland yika is also the
co-director of Quick Step the quantum
Institute there and yikai has worked you
know Works extensively on on both post
Quantum cryptography as well as
new cryptographic instructions including
um including pseudor random Quantum
States so
um I guess um I'll just uh turn to the
panelists and say you know give you a
chance to
um
to your views about the talks
Neta would you like to start or
super enlightening and super interesting
um so I guess my comments will be since
I'm mostly learning with the the other
stuff uh my comments is emotionally on
the quantum gravity applications which
are uh very interesting
so I would actually think that
um one thing that we can
get from eight from ads CHT
for uh Quantum Computing and Quantum
information and understanding pseudo
entanglement uh is actually using the
fact that entanglement should never be
feelable in ads CFT
um just an account of causality and
gravity
so basically causal structure arguments
in gravity would imply have to imply
that it's it should essentially always
be impossible to feel the uh to measure
in a causal way in a simple way the um
the area of an external surface so it's
General's entropy of a Quantum extrema
surface and so I think if we sort of
take that as a prior that you know the
causal structure of gravity is valid in
ads CFT which we we tend to do
um then instead I think what we can say
is is we can ask what are those
pseudoentangled States look like in uh
in holography and as you were giving the
talk I I built a couple on a piece of
paper so
um so I think I can I can tell you what
those are and those are essentially
states where you have one of these or a
special slice of the space tongue
essentially
um looks like one of those Python's
lunches it has it's going to have some
kind of a constriction and then it's
going to sort of have a large are part
of the space-time behind it and I think
what what we can essentially say about
those is that for all holographic
pseudoentangled States
um those are always going to be
computationally indistinguishable from
something like a generalized Gibbs
ensemble which is not the same thing as
saying that they're pseudo-random but
it's actually kind of close
and it so I think that potentially the
the next obvious thing is maybe to
actually be able to show in holography
that um pseudorandom so pseudoentangled
States I actually computationally
indistinguishable from Power random
whenever they're holographic uh and I my
understanding is that you you don't you
don't know that that's true in general
for pseudoentangle states that they're
always going to be pseudorandom you
approved it in your case for the old
construction but it abs-cft would seem
to suggest that maybe this is actually
something which is um true in general
just I I can I can come up with the
proof of you kind of um very quickly
that it's going to be true for all
holographic States
that make two sense yeah no thanks uh
should uh shall we go through the
panelists first yeah okay okay so I'll
hold my car
or you could comment now if you like huh
well yeah there's that they think so
much like this yeah it's it's a really
interesting connection
um that uh so if I understand correctly
you're saying that like basically the
right reference Ensemble for you is to
generalize Gibbs distribution like
that's what would be most interesting to
spoof in in the quantum gravity context
rather than hard random States just
because our random states don't have a
nice gravitational interpretations
that's right it's basically like
something like a generalized uh thermal
state so it doesn't have to be the gift
from someone specifically I was kind of
going for something concrete but in
general the thing that we that that we
understand geometrically uh and we'll
understand as being something that is
indistinguishable if you have uh pseudo
entanglement is going to be one of those
states that we can get using the James
type poor screening where we'll fix some
expectation values of some observables
and we'll maximize the fundament entropy
subject to fixing those application
values and those States we perfectly
understand that your geometric duels and
those will be exactly those states that
our pseudoentangle states and adsc of T
are indistinguishable from
okay interesting interesting yeah I
would love to hear more about the
candidate constructions because yeah I
think like what yeah as I mentioned like
our our currently our pseudoentangle
states they don't have like CFT like or
like nice nice geometrical construction
you know they're they're coming from
this theoretical computer science Avenue
so they they don't kind of naturally
have interpretations so like the fact
that you already have
the fact you already have been on the
spot the uh interpretation is is really
interesting so I can give you one very
common
which I can construct
a full Chrono gravity Theory like it is
safety if you will so I would expect
that the so the Hawking state for black
hole that's evaporating after the page
time that's going to be a state which
looks like it's very uh well the Hawking
State itself is maximally entangled with
some auxiliary system which does not
live in the universe so if you include
the auxiliary system
and you know Universe tensor this
auxiliary system then you have a pure
state which is which is maximally
entangled and if you look at the actual
state of the black hole or the radiation
uh which is purifying then it's going to
be essentially barely not entangled with
the reservoir with this oxidative system
uh but it you know it's computationally
indistinguishable from the Hocking state
so that's another example of a state
that comes up very natural and quantum
gravity which I think is yeah it would
be really cool if what could formalize
this and make a new pseudoentangled
candidate construction that's purely
phrased in quantum gravity terms like
that would that would be that would be
really cool yes I I completely agree
yeah
great thank you
um
Andrew or did you did you want to follow
up
uh yeah sure uh yeah so thanks Adam for
the really nice talk
um so I guess maybe I'll comment a bit
on
the let's say the computational and the
crypto aspects of of the construction
um so you know when you started the talk
you started with this like interesting
motivation of with classical computation
we can view Randomness as a sort of
resource
um to you know like speed up solving
certain problems
um but then people kind of understood
that this actually seems to be a sort of
Mirage because we should be able to
de-randomize
um algorithms and similarly it seems
like entanglement is a resource or
Quantum computation but as you mentioned
like it doesn't seem like we can
de-quantize Quantum algorithms
um so I think it would be interesting
from that perspective to see if
um like what computational insights can
we get from these pseudo-random states
um so for instance you know like there
there was some recent work by
um well a subset of the authors of of
your paper
um showing like an interesting
computational phase transition when you
look at graph States like certain
cluster states that are used for
measurement based Quantum Computing
um and that like when you measure these
cluster States at random angles the
distribution sampled from by this
measurement can be easy or hard to
sample from depending on the
connectivity of these graph States
so I'm wondering if there's like an
analogous thing that one could consider
for either these pseudorandom phase
States or um just like General
pseudoentangle States in general like if
that tells us anything interesting about
computation
um and then on on the cryptographic side
um
so I find it really interesting that
this pseudoentanglement notion really
seems to be a distinct notion from
pseudorandom states in the sense that
you can have pseudo-random states which
are maximally entangled so they're not
you know pseudo-entangled
um like they're not really hiding the
their entanglement in a in that sense
um and you can also have
um like you can also have it in in the
other direction as well
um so you can have sudo entangled states
which are not pseudo-random
um so pseudo-random States we kind of
know especially with the number of
recent works that they lead to
interesting cryptographic applications
so people have used them to construct
commitment schemes digital signatures
and so on
um and there's evidence to suggest that
pseudo-random states can exist even in a
world where one-way functions do not
exist which is like really exciting for
cryptography
um and so this also brings up the
question of like what is where does
pseudoentanglement fit into this picture
so if you care about ensembles of states
that are pseudoentangle but maybe not
necessarily pseudo-random themselves
um where does this fit into the picture
a kind of related question would be can
you always map from a family of
pseudorandom states to a family of
pseudoentangled states or vice versa
um and finally like uh in kind of
relation to uh to my work with with
Matty Hoban
um I think like one interesting
distinction between the pseudoentangle
states that you talked about and and
what we did in our paper
um was that in our paper you're also
given the circuit that produces the
states and even when you're given the
circuit like you know what circuit
produced the States you still can't tell
if the state is
um has large or small entanglement
um so this made me think that maybe
there's this is like a type of public
key pseudo entanglement and and your
version is like a private key
um type of pseudo entanglement and again
this makes me wonder like what in in
what context is one useful
um and like you know it seems like the
private key version can obviously be
based on weaker assumptions than the
public key version
um also in relation to ideas CFT I was
also thinking like is is one notion more
meaningful than the other like in ads
CFT does it matter if you know the
circuit that produces the state or you
know is it just the state the states
themselves that we care about in their
entanglement mm-hmm
yeah there's yeah I uh yeah I'll I'll
reply thanks for the excellent comments
so I'll start with your last question
and then I'll unwind it so
um so yeah it's a great question if you
want like a public key it you you are
absolutely correct and that our
construction is a private Key
Construction and you can ask about a
public Key Construction and I think that
a public Key Construction would be uh
directly applicable like it would give
you a new application to this question
about learning phases of matter
right so the the reason is that uh like
okay let's say like in the physics
context like the more natural input to
their problem is not given copies of the
state but they want to be say given the
description of a local hamiltonian they
want to ask the question is the ground
state of this local hamiltonian does it
have like area law entanglement or
volume law entanglement right so if you
could prove a lower bound you know if
you could create I I think if you could
create a public key version of pseudo
entanglement with kind of 1D aerial
entanglement it would immediately imply
this like a lower Bound for for this
problem right and the reason is that you
could just use like the kataya flock
construction to go from the uh from the
circuit description that prepares the
state which either has lots or little
entanglement to some hamiltonian whose
ground state uh encodes that state of up
to some amount of air right so I think
that that that's the reason like our our
work doesn't yet imply that hardness of
learning phases of matter is that we
have a private Key Construction if we
give you the circuit for the State uh it
gives away the whole problem like you
could immediately tell uh that that that
that that that we're fooling you but by
you know just doing some swap test by
making your own copies of it or
something like this so some sort of uh
uh yeah and like if you similarly if you
if you do the Feynman guitar uh sorry if
you do the ketai of clock construction
to turn a state with a circuit into a
hamiltonian it kind of copies the the
secret key in plain text basically now
you could immediately read it from the
hamiltonian so I I think your lather
suggestion would like is is really
interesting and it might give you this
connection the phases of matter uh I
don't immediately know how it connects
to ads CFT that's that's a great
question as to whether uh a public key
version might be more interesting
um I mean it it might change some of the
connection to this Python's lunch story
that Neda was mentioning where part of
the hardness is coming from some degrees
of freedom you're tracing out over which
for us are the secret keys of of of of
of of the cryptographic construction uh
yeah that's something I find really
interesting to discuss
um yeah great in terms of uh yeah okay
so getting back to some of your other
comments yes pseudo entanglement could
actually be something completely
different from pseudo-randomness like
you can definitely make pseudo-random
states that are not pseudoentangled
um
and uh you can hide some amount of
entanglement without being pseudo-random
I guess I don't yet know of a
construction that hides an exponential
amount of a pseudo uh an exponential
amount of entanglement and is not
pseudo-random I would guess you could
construct something like that because
that that should be like the easy the
easier Direction like it's easier to
take something pseudo random and mess up
it's pseudo-randomeness property then
vice versa but yeah I I that would be
cool like I agree that in principle
there should be some sort of formal
separation there
um that would be interesting
um yeah and in terms of your first
question about you know spoofing
different sorts of entanglement yeah I
agree like a cluster state would be a
very natural place to start you know
there's a very particular sort of
entanglement there if you could make a
low and Tangled version of of a cluster
State then that would imply a
dequantization of some sort of family of
quantum algorithms right so uh you know
fully spoofing a cluster state is
probably like far too much to hope for
right because that would you know that
would presumably dequantize a wide swath
or maybe all Quantum algorithms that
that's too much to hope for but would be
cool if there would be uh it'd be very
interesting if there were some like
subset of quantum algorithms that were
like a natural Target of like okay what
what's the next thing that would that we
might hope to dequantize uh with with
with something like this so yeah that
yeah or you could also go in the other
direction of no-go results and say you
know because of this you can't
dequantize certain certain constructions
oh like yeah there does not exist a way
of making things like this unless some
cryptographic assumption is broken yeah
I see I see interesting
um
sorry um sorry Andre I didn't understand
this last point so you're saying um
in terms of de-quantizing you would you
would say
uh undercrypted you cannot dequantize so
how would you see that going
also yeah I guess it's just a vague
argument but the idea was that
um if um if you could somehow
de-quantize an algorithm that uses a
small amount of entanglement
and at the same time you can show that
in place of that state that is like low
has low entanglement you could use a
pseudo-random state
um then that should give some sort of
contradiction like you would mean that
then you can break the the underlying
cryptographic assumption
at least yeah
yeah or yeah or if you dream up some
stronger cryptographic primitive that
maybe we don't know if it exists or not
and you show that in flies you can spoof
a cluster State then uh yeah that that
should imply that that that stronger
crypto primitive shouldn't exist because
otherwise it would give a right so a
quasi-poly Time factoring algorithm or
something like this right right so I see
okay
um ikai um
it's been you had to wait for a bit but
uh looking forward to your comments oh
thanks yeah yeah so so Adam thank you
for this nice talk I think it's a very
cool result
um so I think I think many of the things
that I find interesting about this have
already been set by by the other
panelists but maybe I can refund some of
those themes a little bit
um you know so
you know so so I'm also interested in
this idea of
when you look at special classes of
quantum States then how can you spoof
those by taking advantage of this
computational indistinguishability you
know so
um
so you know like one example that kind
of interests me is perhaps States for a
two-dimensional local hamiltonians so
these are intuitively these are meant to
to describe the ground states of
two-dimensional sort of quantum
materials
and and I think this is an interesting
class of States because these are really
not computationally tractable the way
matrix product states are but at the
same time they still have a lot of
structure that's very different from our
random States
you know and so yeah I think it's an
interesting question whether a class of
States like these could be spoofed by
some other states that are
computationally indistinguishable from
them but actually have very different
properties
you know part of me doesn't really want
this to be true because if it's true it
kind of it kind of is a big problem for
for our physical understanding of Pep
States and shooting Quantum systems but
you know but I think it's an interesting
kind of foundational question
um and
you know like I guess another class of
states that interests me is is states
that can be prepared by shallow Quantum
circuits
and so these
you know and so these are the kinds of
states that arise in in near-term
demonstrations of quantum Supremacy
and you know and so we can imagine
trying to prepare these states on noisy
quantum computers and we know that these
states are really you know quite
different from the states that we hope
to someday prepare on proper fault
tolerant quantum computers so they're
really special
but at the same time they're also really
not classically tractable
and so there's and so I think it's
interesting to ask
um could these states possibly be
spoofed by very different looking States
or by states that have very different
structure but still look the same in the
sense of computational
indistinguishability
yeah and you know and so
um so I think you know I think that that
the results you've described kind of
give the first indication that there
could be interesting answers to these
questions at all as well
um
and
yeah I guess you know one one last
comment I have is that um
you know so
um
so
I and my co-authors um
like when we were when we were working
on this paper this the the JLS paper
from 2018
um for us we you know it was kind of
we wrote the paper thinking that this
was something that you know that this
notion of a pseudorandom statement
someone ought to Define it because it
seemed like a natural thing you know
just if you look at if you look at the
foundations of classical cryptography
there are pseudorandom generators and so
we felt that this was really a
fundamental object
that that we were talking about but we
weren't really sure what it would be
used for and it's you know and it's so
and so personally it's very nice you
know for me to see that it has found
some uses
um
from my point of view like I actually
wanted
this to be a step towards constructing a
more complicated object called a
pseudorandom unitary
and so this would be a a unitary
operation that would appear pseudorandom
and the pseudorandom state was was
somehow just the first step to towards
constructing a pseudo-random unitary
you know like another way you can think
of it is that is constructing a
pseudorandom unitary object it's like
constructing an orthonormal basis where
every state in that basis is
pseudorandom
and we have some candidate constructions
for this but we could never prove that
they were secure
and yeah and and so I you know I thought
quite a bit about this in the years
after but didn't make much progress with
it
um I think I think my co-authors did too
and yeah and so
um I'm not as optimistic about about
solving that problem but I still think
it's interesting
yeah yeah so you know so again you know
um echoing the fellow panelists um it's
a really cool thing to be working on
yeah great thanks so much for your
comments yeah I I agree that probably
after you wrote your pseudo-random state
paper you probably were not expecting
one of the first applications to be uh
the ads CFT correspondence
in some sense when when you know my
collaboris and I were thinking about the
complexity of ads CFT uh you know we
were hearing all this talk about
complexity equals volume and when you
hear complexity is equal to something
physical you immediately think about you
know natural proofs barrier and and and
to pseudo Randomness barriers to
suffering P versus enfy just how we
started down this kind of pseudo-random
State uh Direction so anyway so yeah
very directly I've inspired some of our
work and really fed into that
um yeah the the question you mentioned
about how they construct the
pseudo-random unitary it's it's a really
great one I think it's pretty difficult
um in terms of uh like I I guess what
what one thing one might hope is like
one could dream that somehow having
lower entanglement prses might might
help you in this but I I still don't see
a direct connection so I think well you
know what you know Adam one we could
think about uh instead I mean it might
be hard to create a pseudo random
unitary but
it might be easier to create a
pseudo-entangled unitary
oh interesting
hmm
yeah yeah like one that uh produces
looks like it makes a lot of
entanglement but but doesn't yes
interesting and then yeah that okay
interesting yeah that would that would
be a totally orthogonal notion to a pru
yeah
yeah well that that's an interesting
suggestion
um
yeah uh with regards to some of your
earlier uh kind of comments uh first you
asked you know is it possible to make
some sort of shallow Quantum circuit
version of our construction it you know
I I don't know the answer off the top of
my head but I think it could be possible
you know like this is in Andrew and
Maddie hoban's prior work that was a lot
of the focus of their result is is
getting these things out the log depth
with long depth lwe constructions now I
do mean to ask though is the most
relevant notion of locality that you're
talking about like spatial locality or
do you mean like uh you know log depth
with Ulta all connectivity you
um
I guess I'd be interested in both
I think if it's all to all conductivity
and law log or poly log depth yeah I I
do wonder if there's a way of making it
work uh with what what what with lwe uh
Andrew you you might have more uh media
comments on this since this is something
you've thought thought a lot about so
yeah I guess
um
probably if you use uh prg constructions
that that are based on lwe I imagine you
could compress that down to to log depth
um I mean there's this uh this nice
paper on
how you can take cryptographic
Primitives that can be performed in in
log depth and then turn them into
constant depth but then you get
unbounded fan out with the with the
constant depth circuit
um and that becomes a bit unfortunate in
in the quantum case but merely for log
depth I I think an lwb-based
construction should work yeah
and this would be log depth all to all
connectivity
all right uh
uh right yeah
um
yeah I'm not sure about yeah like uh
special locality as well
um maybe that's also doable
um but yeah definitely with uh with like
all to all connectivity I think it
should be possible
yeah it could be that try to ask if you
can do it with uh locality might be like
uh you know this is something uh you
know I've discussed quite a bit with
with Bill and eventually it might
require you doing something like
defining a new notion of lwe that has
spatial locality kind of baked in
whereas it the the the vanilla the
off-the-shelf lwe is is not like that
right in the obvious way yeah
yeah I agree when when you start looking
at at very restricted kinds of quantum
circuits then it really
it introduces a lot of technical
complications
[Music]
yeah no that's a great question and yeah
and and yeah also comment a little bit
you asked you know is there any
connection to peps uh you know I think
it it's a really nice question at you
know I think all I can say is that you
know once you have a a quasi-wundy area
law construction that has an MPS you
know it does give you uh a state that
has like a quasi to the area law peps uh
pseudorrendous construction directly by
just snaking your 1D uh pseudo area law
you know across the 2D plane right so we
we can say that there are states with
peps or or you know any finite
dimensional pseudo area law that are
that that are pseudo-random as well and
this might not be directly what you're
looking for though because we just would
then have an upper bound on the
entanglement of these states that's at
most Leica peps
um it wouldn't like the the States you
get what not have peps like entanglement
in the sense that well they but actually
have the integral event of a 1D snake
snaking through your space like they're
actually much less entanglement and like
horizontal directions than in vertical
directions and uh asking if you could
make more peps like pseudo-randomness
would be asking uh it's again an
analogous question can you increase the
entanglement entropy in in certain
directions relative to the low
entanglement uh versions We constructed
so yeah I think that's a really nice
question
yeah and so I think I'm I think I'm also
interested in a slightly different
question which is
um
can you can you make states that are
computationally indistinguishable from
Pep States but have a very different
sort of internal structure
so um
so I'm not sure exactly how to formalize
it which which is making noise so like
you're canonical Ensemble could be
something like a random peps yeah
something like that you want to say I
want some Ensemble states with different
entanglements but our computational
indistinguishable yeah that's very
interesting yeah for instance like we
can probably agree on on what a random
pep state is like on on a mathematical
definition of that and and I'm sort of
curious
um can there be other ensembles that are
computationally indistinguishable from
that
but but have very different
entanglements yeah yeah yeah that that's
a really nice question it's it's really
different than the pseudorendum this
question because yeah the entanglement
structure there is different they have
decay of correlations and all sorts of
other sorts of properties that uh yeah
yeah
and and so like like for matrix product
States
um we know how to answer this question
because for constant Bond Dimension you
can do tomography of an of a matrix
product State efficiently and so and so
therefore kind of there's no ambiguity
about matrix product States
even when you throw in computational
even when you force The Observer to be
computationally bounded sort of a
polynomial time Observer can completely
characterize a matrix product statement
about ambiguity but that's not true for
Pep States
you know like a polynomial time Observer
cannot completely characterize an
unknown pep State and therefore there's
some possibility of that computational
indistinguishability could imply that
there's something weird going on that
you know the state that you think is a
pep State actually it really isn't
um interesting yeah and and yeah I guess
and the point is not occurs even at low
Bond dimension of course with an MPS if
you blow up the bond Dimension to be
like super polynomial then you can start
saying things about indistinguishability
and that's kind of implicitly what what
we're doing in our work right yeah so
like that like but yeah but things get
addressing at lowball Dimension with
peps in the way that yeah they dealt
with MPS for sure yeah yeah yeah so I
guess what yeah like your results
already show that like for matrix
product States would
um poly log Bond dimension
it would be quasi-poly quasi-poly yeah
if it's if it's Polly Vonda mentioned
you the tomography attack you mentioned
would still work or or you can see
another way just say follow us directly
from your entanglement lower bound like
the Schmidt rank across the cut as at
most the bond Dimension if that's only
polynomial then that means there's like
uh you know like if you do a swap test
of two copies first half of two copies
of the States you would have a one over
poly bias uh from that
[Music]
um
yeah
yeah I see yeah okay anyway I'm sorry
for forgetting this of the two technical
no that was that was great um
and any other any other questions so any
other thoughts
well thank you all for a really great
discussion uh Neta uh Andrew
um ikai and of course Adam and uh
and thanks everyone for showing up
um uh we'll see you again next week
great thanks so much for having me
thanks for a great discussion
right
next a lot it was really fun bye-bye
yeah thanks everyone
thanks thanks
thank you